well Jack welcome back thank you it's
nice to be here
nice to have you at Sacred Heart
University I gotta be a little careful
what I say here everybody knows the
truth
winning is an absolutely amazing book
okay and the integrity of your
personality and your character come out
and the fact that you've decided from
the outset to donate all the money from
those books to charity so thanks thank
you that I reminded Jack back in the
back that said grant University is a
charity we'll talk some more
you'd be disappointed if I didn't write
um why'd you write the book well my wife
Susie and I traveled around the world
and we listened to 250 or 300,000 people
ask us questions and you know it's a lot
easier to define yourself and you and
your way of life and your way of doing
business after you've done it and when
you're doing it so in responding to
these questions we really developed if
you will a coda about what leadership is
about how what I really believed in
about the leadership and how it worked
and so we were able to answer just
hundreds and hundreds of questions
hopefully based on a framework that we
developed after seeing those questions
and seeing my my answers to them great
you know I started reading the book
while I was in the Netherlands and was
unable to go to sleep the first night
because I had read the chapter on
mission and values and as a leader of a
small business a small corporation this
university what you said on mission and
values was absolutely fascinating to me
could you elaborate on the importance of
mission for any organization big or
small and then your a particular take on
values we go as behaviors well you know
I really think
then the first time I met you what 20
years ago 15 years ago you want to do
the mission of this school you'd never
forgotten it
it was to build a bigger better
institution but never forget your roots
never forget the people in Bridgeport
allow them to get a second chance of
first education from immigrant families
like you and I were and that's what you
have to do you can't have a mission
that's based on motherhood the mission
has to be very clear we we want it to be
trillion G we wanted to be the most
competitive enterprise in the world and
we want to be number one or number two
and every business we're in oh we wanted
to fix sell it close it and that was
real stuff and if you have a mission
that hangs on the wall quality customers
nice to people that that doesn't do much
for anyone and so you need a clear-cut
mission that identifies where you are
going and and as far as value as a
concern values like integrity caring all
those things that you got to assume
Tegrity is a ticket to the game but then
your values have to be toning really
defined clearly like for example hate
your bureaucracy and the bureaucrats
that practice it that's clear share
ideas so you can't end up talking about
that value of sharing ideas and then
have a manager or a leader who's holding
on to ideas and not sharing their people
so you've got to manage that way you
can't say that you believe in integrity
and then have somebody do something bad
and let them sneak out the door because
the lawyers say you can't really say
you're gonna hang them in a square
you've got to let people know when they
do something wrong they didn't need for
personal reasons they left because they
didn't have the day
and so if you manage that way and you
make your value you reward what you talk
about for values and you punish those
who don't have it or you ask them to
move on because they don't have your
values then I think you you you have a
right that it'll the best way to get you
to win and fulfill the mission and when
you talked about the mission you were
very specific about what you meant by
mission and also who should develop the
mission what the mission look I think
the values are developed a lot by the
people in the organization they should
bubble up they should talk about it they
you could write values I'm in Oakland
Connie and I several times write writing
values things over and over again same
the Croton ville having people play with
them to get the feel for what was right
but a mission is really your job it was
my job and my top team struck the idea
of letting a thousand people come up on
the mission is nuts just plain nuts the
leaders job is to find the mission and
then have the people participate in the
values to achieve that mission it's
great that was very very helpful to me
as I've been thinking about our new
strategic planning efforts here and of
the importance of focusing on that
direction for the next 10 years so
thanks for helping us with that and you
know you don't want to be a phony I mean
a leader that goes around saying what do
you think about our mission you really
looking for some help there you want to
tell them what the mission is and you
want values to be worked on by everyone
you make a big point in the book about
the importance of candor yeah how do we
create a culture of candor in this
organization or any other and
particularly when as you pointed out
almost from the beginning we're told to
be less than candid well first of all
you reward it and you demonstrate it
every time you have a chance you
demonstrate straightforward candid
discussion and that's part of you and
your style and it has to be and you
can't end up being a you know
less than open transparent candid person
and if you are there's no chance of
developing in it if people demonstrate
candy you reward the people don't you
don't want them you deal with them
and and it look you don't get it all
beside and but you keep talking about it
every one of these things that you want
you've got to keep talking about till
you almost want a gag on it you say it
so many times and it's something that
you just keep demonstrating over and
over again and eventually you get a
majority of the crowd they you never get
everybody but you keep trying all the
time but you think you've got people
actually by the time you were at GE for
10-15 years that they were honestly
willing to be candid with you somewhere
some in this room are probably too can
you got a position of power you get a
little nonsense that comes with it right
right you've taken a lot of heat over
the years over the concept of
differentiation but you keep holding on
to it as being absolutely critical is it
cruel in Darwinian or is it fair and
effective I can't think of a better way
and obviously we all know what it is
it's 20% of the people your best you
know it that's not precise but
directionally 20% of the people are your
best you let them know it you reward
them you want them in the soul your
reward in the wallet you wanted to get
rich you wanted to have a great job um
they're fun middle set 70 you you reward
but you tell them all the time where
they stand and then the bottom 10 you
ask to move on you don't waste a lot of
time trying to move them up and frankly
once you do that people don't hang
around the idea the idea differentiation
is cruel you tell me a better way every
time every person in this room who
manages someone whether it's a pizza
place whether it's a restaurant a
laundry or anything every one of you has
an obligation to every person that works
for you to let them know where they
stand
the job of leader is to let people know
what they said it's an obligation the
thing I say that happens Tony even
people who say it's true and Darwin I
believe that I think Mendes said it when
when she introduced me that business is
like sports the team that feels the best
players wins and it's that simple and
differentiation helps you keep upgrading
the team and the idea that it's cruel to
tell somebody than the bottom 10% let me
tell you what happens and some some of
you may be familiar with this and you've
had recessions and other difficult times
the minute every session hits the boss
figures they able to take out 20% of the
cost of 25% of the cost whatever it is
they walk down the hall they walk into
somebody's office a Joe for example they
walk in was office and they'll say Joe
we got to cut costs and we're gonna have
to let you go and then Joe says why me
and the boss says well you weren't that
good Joe and Joe said but I've been here
23 years and you've never told me that's
what's cruel it's only the weak managers
who do that who surprised people who
fake it don't tell people where they
stand and allow them to make their
choices earlier in life I found that out
the hard way I took over GE in 1980 and
we had a very large bureaucracy and we
were not becoming competitive we had a
great company built by great people but
we had the Japanese coming at us and we
had lots of problems and a lot of people
had to be let go and lots of people had
phony appraisals and they'd walked down
the hall then or they'd said something
in by the mayor where where where their
boss had been telling him for years
we used to fall in this set what are you
career ambitions and that everyone would
write my boss his job then the boss
would look at it won't 100 once a year
and check off fully qualified and that
was the end of the use of the human
resource equation and that's just plain
wrong and so people have being misled
when people
being trolled where they stand so every
one of you that leads somebody has a
responsibility to tell them where they
stand
I couldn't agree with you more tough job
though we shy away from that kind of
candor most of the times don't we yeah
but you can't it's not fair it's wrong
it's mean it's people say I'm true kind
of manager to tell somebody they're not
that good that's not being kind that's
being cruel thanks for that perspective
when you were chairman of GE how did you
spend most of your time hanging around
with bill Conti looking for people you
know the crazy thing about this is and I
wrote about in the book here and and and
I if I find it everywhere everywhere I
go when I ask people in annoyance my
wife sir
associate Iver in Mexico and I was
talking to 5,000 8 HR executives and I
asked a pretty simple question how many
of you in the audience perceive yourself
as having eight yet I perceived by the
organization as having a seat at the
table equal to the CFO out of 5,000
people I literally did not get 50 now
tell me why if you were running a team
you would want to hang around with the
team accountants versus the head of
player personnel why why people want to
hang around and we have Keith Sharon
who's a CFO so wonderful guy but why
would you want to hang around with him
all day I mean why would you want to
hang around with
the phone the human resource person has
all the tickets to make you have a great
team and yet CEO after CEO all over this
country is glomming on to the CFO and
this any HR person that can really help
them build a great organization it's
down there if you went to GE and asked
that question you would get 90 percent
of the people would say they have an
equal seat at the table with the city
with the CFO and at the top of the
organization's and every business you'd
feel that they had that role and that is
a key to developing people having great
HR people you know Bill Kennedy to GE
senior vice president for human
resources has been an outstanding member
of our Board of Trustees
thanks for sharing him with us when when
you were chairman and since I've read
the book I do refer to him as pastor
bill now he's posturing permanent
pasture in parent that's a good thank
you I was very intrigued with the for
ease and the tea in the book and that
section of the book could you elaborate
a little bit on on that part of the yeah
everyone has their own code of how they
hire how they evaluate and there's no
perfect method every one of these things
that's in there is a view that I have
but it isn't the only view that is out
there but I believe when you look at
people I always look for 440s energy the
ability to energize others ii ii excite
them get them involved in the mission
the third was edge the ability to say
yes or no and not maybe then the fourth
e is executed get it done and then i
talked about we always like people that
had passion passion for it kid more than
the next person
so for reason the p became a sort of
mantra of mine well how we evaluated
people for future careers and it worked
pretty damn well if you look at all the
leaders that GE has developed over the
years in addition to the for ease and
the p the work
process has made a huge difference in
the general electric is it a useful
process for other organizations colleges
universities hospitals other businesses
to look at anybody that wants to get
everybody in the game every anyone who
believes that getting everyone in the
game counts and getting ideas from
anywhere and there and the best idea
counts not the stripes on the shoulder
it's a winning idea I mean it's it takes
time you have to build trust people
don't believe you you have to listen to
things like the food in the cafeteria
stinks the driving is no good you hear
every complaint you overhear but in the
end you get people to say hey they care
we had a person in Louisville that told
us one one day in a review should you
know for 25 years you've been paying for
my arms and my legs you could've had my
brain for nothing you never asked and I
think every organization has to think
about that all the time the people
closest to work do in fact know to work
better no good you know I I said to you
when you walked into my office a few
minutes before we came over you
continued to be absolutely amazing when
is the passion come from what keeps you
going what are you excited about well
we're getting his life in the world why
wouldn't that be exciting
I mean I got a sensational wife before
great step kids and for my own good kids
you got a speaking gig that they go
around around the world speaking it's
almost white-collar crime
yeah I can sell for a bunch of people I
mean it's it's great and I get five
newspapers in the morning and I'm gonna
tell them soon and I get breakfast in
bed well that's great sounds great spot
Sicilians what more could you ask
that's great it's terrific Jack let me
shift gears if I might today's program
is actually sponsored by the
University's College of Business
secretary University has one of the
largest MBA programs in the state and
the preparation of people in the field
of management this business was among
our first majors when we were founded in
1963 there'll be a graduation next
weekend will graduate 1500 students at
the undergraduate and graduate levels
what advice do you give to those young
women and men but who are going out
perhaps with their first job into
today's environment well I I've been on
this circuit for a while and I thought
about it and I have three things I like
to tell young graduates today and the
one of the things is that's schools in
some in some ways while they prepare
them so well they also have one flaw
that sticks with people the first thing
is over-deliver every time a student is
when you work it in a business and
you're asked to do something if you just
do what the boss asked you to do you
will end up just confirming what the
boss wanted to have written down they
already knew the answer when they asked
the question so your job and a new job
is to over the living give them new
perspectives when anybody has some
schools ask you for a problem problem
solving in a case then they ask you the
questions so you answer the questions
you don't get the answer you don't get
the questions in business you have to
develop a perspective that's wider and I
always tell the story of my of my first
job I was a project manager in a little
plastic operation in Pittsfield Mass and
my boss from New York was coming up just
my boss my boss's boss and they wanted
me to come in one of those gee white
shirt pitches the represent the cases
for my new plastic tell them where where
I was going so I got all prepared
nothing else but what I did what I did
do was I didn't talk about my project
alone I talked about the ten plastics in
the industry where they were gonna be in
five years their cost structure from to
tout cela nice to Pont etc I give up
that pact I gave my boy my boss's boss
this picture of the industry I think
that's how I got noticed there I was I
got out of the pile because I didn't
just give him my project report his what
I did yesterday if I get tomorrow hazard
will do next day I gave him a
perspective and made him look smarter he
now knew more about the industry than he
ever knew and that's what you want to do
you always want to over-deliver never do
what the assignments do more than that
wider new insights new horizons that
secondly you gotta walk around with a
positive attitude no one wants a black
cloud around them all day get rid of it
don't bring it to work it's a disaster
it's a career killer just don't do it
and the third thing is don't be
ambitious be ambitious but don't be
ambitious to the point that it's on your
forehead and a neon sign don't do it do
it privately have all the ambition in
the world but don't go in and rub it in
everyone's nose so with those three
things over deliver a positive act and
attitude don't wear ambition on your
forehead I think you'd be after a pretty
good stat it's great
and how about mentor mentors how
important is it for these young people
to find the mentor as they begin never
never find a mentor
it's the worst idea ever invented
mentors are good to show show you where
the cafeteria is where to fill health
insurance policies you should attack
mentors this way there's somebody that
you're gonna go to work with who's gonna
be a great speaker somebody who's gonna
be a great marketing everyone in the
place is a potential mentor if you get
stuck with one mentor just I really get
on this one I mean obviously with one
mentor what happens if your mentor gets
shot so you don't want to do that you
want to always go talk to people who are
who you perceive as being good at
something that could help you if you do
that first of all they'll be flattered
to pieces and will pour out everything
they ever knew and then some so you'll
get lots of stuff set up so everyone is
a mentor everyone loses a mentor and
think of it that way and don't be afraid
to go ask we always went on G and asked
other companies how they give their
inventory how they get other things hey
they'd love to tell you you can learn so
much always go with an attitude that
somebody can teach you something that's
number one and the second thing about
about Memphis you ought to think about
is the business press they're great
ventures you should be I'm shocked when
I asked some MBAs that they don't get
fortune Forbes Business Week they don't
get the Wall Street Journal every day
you should get all that stuff it won't
all be right some little be wrong some
of me but there's a language and a
rhythm of business and you've got to
know everything that's going on
for example Morgan Stanley's now in a
mess with the with the old God coming
back trying to take take over the
company
the current CEOs fighting to hold on
there's a whole argue that you want to
be forming if you're a student you want
to form your opinion what should happen
why shouldn't have and there's a
front-page story in every magazine every
month now on this subject you want to be
right in the middle of it so you can be
at a party the generalist you can form
your ideas about it you can chat with
people
get in the mix business has a rhythm
business has a language and you want to
be in every day so mentoring is as wide
as your eyes can see not some one person
it's gonna string you along with a rope
the bug can break too easily daddy want
to tell us what you really think about
mentors or I well I got some other
supress they give me the this morning as
I was walking into my office so when a
student says stopped me and said I can't
be here today because I've got to get
home because my mom's sick but could you
please ask mr. Welsh one one question so
I promised her that I would and her
question is what's your outlook on the
economy for the next five years well
five years is far beyond my job great
okay but I can give you you know I I
have this incredible view of the economy
that said when I go out I'm getting a
lot of hand-wringing you know number of
places that I go so many people are
watching lou dobbs at night i mean it's
it's crazy let's take a look at the
economy right now let me before I do
that though take you back to the day I
got the job in December of 1980 in 1980
when I get the job did about their
coming out the prime rate was twenty
three and a half percent crime rate the
interest rates were fourteen percent
unemployment was 13 percent and the
gross national product had declined for
nine straight quarters and the President
of the United States
Jimmy Carter had declared the country in
malaise as the Japanese were taking over
the world today we got a GDP that's
growing three to four percent for the
last eight quarters unemployment's at
five the prime rates of six inflation's
can change in the three percent range
things are really good things are really
great we just added jordan says seventy
five thousand jobs and laugh
last month just announced this morning
this economy is booming him as I go
around at school the jobs everywhere an
opportunity server and I see only people
starting new businesses entrepreneurs
starting new businesses they enter as
good as I've seen seen them in years and
years and years and the kids are as
optimistic as I ever seen them
despite a sort of hand-wringing overtone
that comes out of some of the media
check one last question before we open
it up to questions from the audience
but a Catholic Church has gone through a
major transition a new pope after 26
years a major scandal here in the United
States this is a Catholic University
what advice would you give to the
Catholic Church at this stage mrs. Welch
did not bring up a fool very good well
how about I suggest that all the bishops
read winning how's that for a very good
okay well we've got some time for
questions from the audience and I'll ask
you to come forward to the microphone
and I'll recognize somebody on the right
and then on the left and then after we
finish the question and answer period
there'll be a chance for you to get your
books autographed by mr. Welsh next door
and perhaps if you wouldn't mind
identifying yourself that would be great
I can fell on bond boys and girls in
Milford see a great necktie today Jack
thank you I love that next time I really
like the fact that in your book you talk
about elevating the importance of the HR
person view yourself modeled that for
the amount of time you spend with people
when you visit somewhere and then
following up with the notes how did you
do that and still respect the chain of
command and not feel some of those
people in how did you do that with
reaching down several levels okay I
guess I just think that's the whole game
and the people that I that we had
working for us also did the same thing
with
with their organizations I I think it
was the behavior that went again we
define that as a behavior we wanted
everyone counted we want voice and
dignity we want everybody in the game
and so if some jerk didn't want you near
his people worried you you hopefully
found him and got him out of it so I
mean the whole idea is demonstrate the
behavior that you want measure it reward
it and it was very easy I mean look it's
more fun who was to sit in an office and
play with papers it's not even close and
the only way when you do it when you do
it you build the team you find the best
players we used to call battlefield
Commission's would see some stars
somewhere wouldn't give him a
battlefield commission it wasn't it was
incredible the the energy he get from
these people that were out there and
it's the only game in China I mean the
idea of not of not the one of the
dangers of the Internet is faceless
communication it's a real issue
I mean it's you've got to go touch this
stuff thank you and please on on this
side yeah hi Jack I'm John prim ski and
I own my own business here in
Connecticut entrepreneur person but the
question with always you read right now
about China import quotas price controls
things like that I traveled to China
three times a ship sort of very vibrant
entrepreneurial economy over there I
wonder what your thoughts are on this
whole issue of China or price controls
and quotas things like that well so so
far it's very low-level talk and let's
let's pray to God stays there I think we
all know China you've been there three
times this year this year more than I
have it's vibrant it's on fire that
there's an energy of palpable energy in
the air that they're great players
they're also great that they're not just
a threat they're an opportunity there's
two things this thing they're they're an
opportunity to partner with them there's
all kinds of joint ventures there's all
kinds of deals as long as it's a win-win
if you go to China where it's a win
you're dead but if you go there with a
win-win attitude there's all kinds of
opportunity use their intellect their
energy their distribution the number of
people it is I see it as at least half
full there may be more Thanks
this side please jack Frank Donovan GE
Fairfield not as well as you and Chris
Matthews early macro neither be ELISA
but I am proud to be senior elephants I
want to see you one of these days let's
talk about us higher education I got
winning here and I want you to sign up a
Phyllis of me but I also think that
we've got to take a hard look at u.s.
higher education I think they gave a
very high opinion of themselves in many
ways and they don't live up to their
great potential that they should have
and operating not only efficiently but
well for both the students the parents
the teachers and a truly win-win
situation for themselves in America this
Larry Summers situation is only the tip
of the iceberg what's your what can be
done to really make us higher education
it live up to its own expectations and
its own self reputation well you know I
used to listen to that voice when I went
to bed at University message WMU a 91.1
dump you anyway he was the voice of
UMass now no one listens to me jack not
even you
and Frank I think the problem starts all
over I think higher education in the in
the u.s. is the strongest point of our
educational system by an order of
magnitude our problems start we're in we
were up in the in in New Haven today at
a lunch for read to grow which is a an
organization the Haven area that gives a
book and a package of 30 materials to
every newborn in the New Haven area and
if the numbers are even close to right
this organization had a chart upon the
board with numbers that 73 percent of
the of the people in Hartford all
citizens people happen 73 percent can
only sign their name and can't read
that's an incredible statistic if that's
even close to right but that's that they
had up there in their child 42% in the
state so our problem starts much earlier
and our problem is not hiring a higher
education Frank with all its flaws is is
unparalleled in the world I think that
Bill Cosby and Barack Obama on to
something here on dealing with the inner
cities but they're being crucified for
thanks thanks I'm mr. Walsh my name is
Bill Moens I work in marketing for
Citibank and I'm also MBA student here
at say for being a neighbor of Sacred
Heart University for several years and
also a leader in business you've had the
opportunity to watch us grow and develop
throughout the years what advice do you
have in an ever competitive educational
environment to continue that growth I
think the job that's been done here is
almost beyond belief when you think of a
school that 15 years ago had 300,000
square feet and now is a million three
that has this incredible faculty that
they did they had almost nothing before
mostly gay students coming in here I
think you can never you can't I think
the biggest danger here is getting too
big for your britches I think you got to
remember your core mission here
you're getting great kids the SATs in
the average or 1100 or so and Tony was
saying that he still gets a lot of
innocent city kids that they have
programs for and do well with I think
you got to remember that every day your
life it's not to be the fair I I know
every graduate wants it to be the
fanciest place in the world but let me
tell you the job that schools like this
do is an incredible thing we're in Serge
and I are in Salem State last night
which is a state school isn't even the
UMass system the average SAT going
there's 850 and 900 we saw some of the
most impressive kids in the world have
fabulous kids knows against the glass
want to win after it and this school
where the president's been there 15
years they're so proud of the mission
they have we're just taking these kids
that don't have two nickels to rub
together and educating them and sacred
hospital champion of this if Tony have
done a remarkable job just don't get too
big for your britches thank you on this
side please hi jack I'm a graduating
senior about to enter the business world
in about two weeks so as you look back
on your career and you know it's viewed
as a obviously one of the most
successful careers in business ever what
would you say if you can go back and
change one thing what would it be why
would I want to change and be so
outrageous for me to complain about what
I got now and what I do differently I'm
so lucky
I'm just gonna enjoy it thank you
hello mr. Welch it's a real honor to get
to ask you a question
I know from reading your books that you
encourage and our fond of
entrepreneurship having taken the
three-year chance at being an
entrepreneur I I didn't win I failed I
wonder if you could offer a an
entrepreneur some some counsel on
re-entering a place trying to re-enter a
place like GE and how to sort of deal
with that failure well the first thing I
do is find Conaty if I couldn't find him
tonight I would I would make the case by
having the guts to do what you did I
think it is a remarkable thing to see
people though it take take a swing and
you give you a young age you took a
swing you lay out what your high was
what you took a swing at and lay out why
it didn't work with a very real the fact
that you are so realistic it didn't work
I didn't when you're already ahead of
the game you face reality
now lay out why and go make your case to
some company who will be luck you have
to have somebody with your guts Thanks
hi mr. Willis my name is Nick Kerry I'm
a business student here at Sacred Heart
I appreciate your comments on ambition
and positive attitude and over delivery
I was just wondering for a student who's
leaving University with a lot of
interest in the business world finance
real estate management what would you
recommend a student get started or once
he's graduate how to really find an
Asian gained experience assert a career
and that's so individual I mean if
there's no way I can answer that that's
a generic question I mean finds it we've
got a page 257 in the book did you take
gives you a very good grid as to five
things to think about when you think
about a company or where you're going to
work or what you're going to do the
people you work with the opportunities
it provides the options it provides you
know your deal with yourself on
ownership and the work content does it
turn your crank go through page 257 and
every time you're looking at a job
laying against that grid now I I have a
a friend of mine who's a radiologist in
Boston who has to shoot my back off and
their bad back and I want to hit the
ball he shoots me with needles and I go
over and see him a lot he's got a red
vest on everything else but I gave him
the book about a month ago when I first
had that book I said take a look at the
book and he said well what should I look
at and I said take page 257 take a look
at he goes down the five things he said
I gotta get the hell out of radiology
for 25 years mr. Welsh thank you very
much
I'm in the entrepreneurial industry in
both education and internet marketing do
you want to make a plug for higher
education can I think it by the way it
sits I've met many educators in many
different parts of the state and I think
you're doing a tremendous job so I'd
like to hear for education also for
being an entrepreneur I've been at it
for about three and a half years and I'm
experiencing a lot of success
and I would recommend it to anyone who
has the fortitude to go out and do it
aside from periodicals Businessweek
Forbes fortune what else have you read
this year and what would you recommend
aspiring business people and
entrepreneurs to read well you know I've
I read them I read sort of the business
inside stuff I read conspiracy of fools
I loved it it was the inside baseball on
Enron I mean really nitty-gritty stuff I
read the Disney was so gossipy thing on
Disney so I wouldn't put my reading
habits against something that's going to
help you a lot they were sort of
intriguing and fun to read but I don't
have a Bible the only thing I'd be if I
were you was winning
it's a hell of a book afternoon mr.
wells my name is IRA Walt close but no
cigar
I'm a native son of bridgeport earlier
in your conversation you touched on
missions about fixed seller clothes at
one time GE was the largest employer I
believe in the city of Bridgeport the
city today suffers from its absence
could you revisit the decisions that
that led to that and touch upon possibly
what might have been clearly the thing
that I had a lot of trouble with and it
spent a lot of time with and I think
it's hard for a lot of people to grasp
is that companies don't provide job
security customers provide job security
only satisfied customers provide job
security no matter how much goodwill you
have or how much you love the company if
you don't have a customer look at those
dot-coms are the last 10 years of the
nineties to understand that if you're
not getting revenue if you're not
competitive you can't play
we had a wiring cable business there
that was totally uncompetitive we had a
housewares business that we had to get
out of and eventually Black and Decker
took at all overseas you just didn't
have we had all line commodity
industries and commodity hell is an
awful place to be if you're making stuff
that everybody else can make you're in
real trouble and in the products we had
in Bridgeport and Pittsfield Mass when
we had transformers where we had lost my
money for 23 years you can't carry those
long-term it hurts everybody GE has been
layoffs in years the thriving company
because we got competitive but only
satisfied customers can create jobs and
all of you who had that entrepreneur
that was here the one that had the bad
luck he didn't have the customers that's
all the way we went along
Goodfellow liked his people good guy but
he couldn't worry about it because he
didn't have satisfied customers the last
gentleman was just here after three and
a half years said he's thriving
a pitcher if you ask him yet satisfied
customers
that's what it all is about I see Bill
Mitchell here in the front row and and
and he spends all his life with
satisfied customers so but he wouldn't
he'd close the store down if customers
more boy one says by despite the fact
that had been the most generous people
in in Fairfield County in that store but
they can't do it if they're not winning
if they're not getting satisfied
customers that's the only way it works
I'm sorry by Bill McGuirk Rockville bank
Connecticut's best Community Bank and
you deserve to be the executive this
century thank you ethics at all levels I
think is a core problem in America today
and I'm wondering what's your take on
and what you do about it
see I I think we've had some bad apples
there's been some bad behavior I think
as I've gone around to 22 business
schools now I see its top of mind so
that's gonna be a generation coming out
with a lot of Education from this mess
yeah we have some scandals at the end of
the of the surge there but what
companies don't have that I mean good
companies fight every day it's it's
unreasonable to think that a company
would X number of 5,000 people is going
to have all the perfect people but you
train you having a value you publicly as
we talked about your publicly hanging
people who violate it you run online
systems to to check people in gray areas
and people pass the test or they don't
you you live it all the time it's the
only way to do it and you can't do it by
your giving a speech you do it by
actions all the time and the stories we
had whether it be Enron or wouldn't be
Tyco these are places I just tragedies
that we'll all learn from and that's
what got us aa Bains Oxley which in fact
will bring back conference and and among
other things thank you before we take
the next question just let me suggest
that no one else enter the question line
because we'll give those of you on the
line a chance and then we'll adjourn
into the mahogany room mr. Welch palter
quality from Wachovia small business
lending I first I just wanted to thank
you for you
I meant can you help the first fellow
that was here will talk after
first I wanted to personally thank you
for when after I read straight from the
gut I had been working in a smaller
community bank and with very little
accountability for their staff and that
might just be my opinion but I think it
was a reality and after reading that the
motivation behind your style of writing
your style of managing was such a
powerful thing that even though all the
accolades were there and writing for me
at this particular Bank my next step was
to go towards a larger bank obviously
but I thank you for that because that
was personally from that from that
acceleration my question is do you think
that differentiation would be something
that a government type situation would
benefit from in any aspect of that
without getting political well would it
benefit the answer is absolutely yes can
it be done I don't think so
I mean that's that's one of the awful
things we have out here and that's and
that's a product about system that we
don't have that and I I don't think many
of the tools and winning applied to the
government sector unfortunately they may
apply to the private sector though and
they pride in their pride of nonprofits
as well as profits but I don't think
they did they apply to a government
system very very well I mean if you
can't differentiate if you can't
recognize individuality if you can't
reward on merit if you can't do all
these things it's a tough goal
it's a tough go
mr. Welch my name is Mike Garbarino I'm
gonna graduating from Sacred Heart and a
few weeks my counterparts here and my
question isn't really for the number one
the number two guy working through their
company and working with it this is for
the third and fourth string who are
working below someone and are having
trouble dealing with complacency and
stagnation in the company or in any line
of field what advice can you give to
someone who doesn't necessarily have the
final say on things in dealing with that
within their own departments well I have
a chapter in here called that damn boss
and wimp and when you're dealing with a
boss you've got a really understand
first thing you have to do is you're
gonna find out is it really this company
or the boss or is it you so you gotta go
give yourself a good mirror test is it
really somebody else or your problem and
if you if you satisfy yourself that it's
really the boss or the system you're
then gonna take it on recognizing the
perils of what you're doing so you've
got to have options you have to be
looking elsewhere you gotta be doing all
that stuff but you can never be a victim
that question implies victimhood and I
don't accept anybody being stuck without
having a chance to do something else if
you're stuck in a place have the courage
to move on and try something else go
don't stay and mom it's a killer it
kills you you know go home and kick the
dog punch the spouse yeah all those
things are horrible events and you can't
sit and moan you got to either realize
if it's you if you're comfortable it's
not you deal with it with your boss and
if that doesn't work a while you're
doing that be looking elsewhere thank
you
hi mr. Welsh I'm Marion Hampel and I
started at the Bridgeport plant in 1973
as a file clerk and I've been telling
everyone for years that if I ever had
the opportunity to say thank you I would
because of GE where I still work today
in Fairfield I've got my bachelor's
degree and my MBA degree from Sacred
Heart University and that was all
because
so I wanted to say thank you very much I
remember the day that you became the CEO
of GE so thank you thank you so much I
get up here mr. Walsh my name is Huell
Oh Thomas I currently work for a small
financial services vendor I'm looking to
start my own software company which I
want to talk to you about afterwards I'm
gonna give you my card as well but I
have dealt with that with GE and GE
Capital on a number of certain and a
number of situations as a small provider
and small software vendors what advice
would you give to small companies
dealing with large companies such as GE
when they are very very competitive and
looking always of course to get the best
product for the best price and so quite
often putting a lot of pressure on a
small vendor because they are because
they ask for have the best price in the
best product
I don't know you good um one of the
things that I've wrong to know about you
from working with you is that you truly
have a genius for understanding people's
potentials and bringing them beyond
their potentials and I see in aspects of
from talking to the made to business
executives and powerful people
how can you share that with the rest of
us I'm cultivating that being able to
understand and bring that potential up
chat give the right answer we hope both
you get hurt on this one well I think
it's what it's what turned you on if
that turns one for me managing and
leading is like walking around with a
can of fertilizer in one hand and a can
of water in the other hand and the
employees of seeds and you water the god
and you you get a kick out of seeing the
flowers grow and when you get a few
weeds you cut them out that's how it
works and you just and you get turned on
I mean we used to sit and get a list of
stock option sheets from every month on
the people Kashmere not options and the
true no wasn't what we were getting we
already had our pile the Turner was
seeing the success of other people
letting him reach letting him dream if
you have fun doing that I mean the fact
that we have four guys that work for
Bill myself
you've got still a bunch of us that work
for us now when four of the Dow Jones
230 that's a kick it's exciting the
factory of all these CEOs that run these
for Fortune 590 of these 35 or something
whatever the number is that's a kick if
if that's what excites you seeing people
grow if seeing people win excites you
you'll get it and if they know you care
about them they'll get they'll deliver
beyond their their wildest dreams just
like you did I mean I never thought I'd
have this jump Joanie you kidding me
wild
and I got it and it felt great and I
wanted a lot of other people to feel the
same stuff so I'm use any formula I
think it's really caring the only thing
it's getting excited about other people
doing what they never thought they could
do that's a great question I never had
it before
hi my name is James Lavin I'm author of
management secrets of the New England
Patriots and I believe you're a big
Patriots fan as well and I see great
similarities between your leadership
style and Bill Belichick's and I'd like
to ask you if you agree and also I'd
like to give you a signed copy since
you're signing everybody else's books
today no no I think I don't know Bill
Belichick that well I admire the team
he's built around at me he rover Romeo
Crennel Charlie Weis I think what he did
if he did anything is what I did then
the idea that Jack Welsh could make G do
all these things is ludicrous Jeff a
melt or a reg jaws be bit before me it's
all about getting great people this is
not just a slogan in a speech this is
really true you hire great people the
ballgame is it's over so Bill Belichick
when I haven't got Romeo is now in
Cleveland with the Browns and Charlie's
at Notre Dame we'll see how good he was
and bringing up those but he had some
guys underneath see one of the problems
that happens in corporate America's
giving it on the second is that the
problem of a lot of excesses and
problems that have gone on in corporate
America is because companies didn't have
succession plans now Bill Belichick had
a plan for Romeo leaving and Charlie
going he push up to internal guys of
motive but when Carly Fiorina had her
problem and you had um when when Lou
plan that we moved from hewlett-packard
they had to go look for a CEO so they go
outside and they hire somebody from the
outside and they gotta get
these huge severance packages and big
money and all these things so the
problem comes at the front end when Jeff
Immelt
got the GE job the board said
congratulations Jeff you've won here's a
twenty five percent raise whatever the
number was nice going Nadella he stood
there and McNerney stood there in 3m
drove a Brinks truck up but McNerney be
Home Depot truck drove up and bought na
deli and Porsche everyone but he got
their normal deal and so what happens is
when companies don't have succession
plans companies have to go out and buy
them all these complaints about this
person getting twenty million dollars in
this person yeah getting the ed green
who went to Tyco he he went to Tyco
because Kozlowski going down the drain
and they had no successor so when they
go out and take somebody to Motorola
they have to go out and make a deal with
them if you come here we'll give you
this there's this system is the guy says
but I want this this and this and that
they have nothing to do but saying yes
and then the desert won't work out if it
does work out well it doesn't work out
we have scandalous stories about Severn
space but the severance came about
because the board and the human resource
people weren't delivering succession
plans and that's the issue so I think
Bill Belichick don't great leaders and
then he's just replaced won't see how he
does G's doing very well now with the
team that was there one more thing thank
you afterwards when I'll see you in line
with your book
hello mr. Walsh my name is Felice great
Kemp I'm a senior finance attorney with
United Technologies Corp mr. Mitchell is
a family friend and I think I met you
with my husband about six years ago and
some things you said is your shopping
but I still resonate with me and one of
the things that you mentioned there is
in your book was about the importance to
remain authentic not just in your
business dealings but in your daily life
and since everyone has come ahead of me
and in your book and in your
presentation you've answered my
questions I want to bring you some
questions from my mentees who came to me
organically just so you know and aren't
part of a program and that is how does
they remain authentic particularly in
light of the fact that a number of them
are as you and your book have written
our first generation professionals how
do you remain authentic in a world that
essentially suggests that you need to
learn how to play certain sports or eat
with the right fork and still be a
corporate player but I I just happen to
believe being authentic is the most
lasting thing you have and it will
always pay off be comfortable in your
own shoes and talk to Bill afterwards
the economy of we always measured people
and how authentic they were and how
comfortable they were with themselves
not where they went to school not what
they pretended to be but who they really
were and how comfortable they felt with
themselves and I think if you can just
pound home take kids if they're getting
penalized for that then they got to
evaluate what we want to do but start
out as long as you can be yourself
I mean and I from my standpoint I I
would argue it's the only way to live
life
be yourself take the heat when people
don't don't don't like it get whacked
around if people don't like it but be
yourself never walk in somebody else's
shoes it's crazy
yeah the universe is held together by
keeping certain forces in complementary
relationship to one another it would be
inconceivable to me if we end it without
giving Bill Mitchell a chance to ask mr.
Welsh a question come on Billy you got
an audience e it don't pass it up when
you reduce everything to leadership
whatever you like round the six turn
around the seven with common sense
talk to us about common sense in your
life well I think it's really though
you've lived that life I mean but it it
isn't complicated I mean the last time
you graduates will ever do a model is
last week you'll never it'll be the
problem with most business schools I
can't say I said about here but the
problem is most business schools were
built we've in all the big fancy ones on
the East the best in the Midwest and the
best on the west is they don't teach
enough the only place we went with where
they were evaluating each other in a
rigorous fashion was that talketh
Tuesday nights the only school we saw
that was absolutely having people
appraised each other evaluate each other
that's never done that's what you do
when you get a job you hire people you
evaluate them you motivate them you
remove them if they're not doing the job
those are the skills that business will
have to do so much more of so I would
argue bill that this idea of caught off
common senses of what you're talking
about
it's what business is it's all coming as
it's pattern recognition though you know
now what sells and you know what doesn't
sell and therefore you're able to buy
much better than you could when you were
20 and you're able to make faster
decisions because you've done them
enough times every one of these things
you will do you will
learn from trying something if it
succeeds you'll try something a little
more if that's exceeds you'll reach a
little further but it's all something
that will develop and that is the
learning that will come to you is
pattern recognition which is called
common sense it's the same thing it's
doing things it's called gut it's called
common sense but it's really something
you learn by doing and every time you
get a success with it you get a
self-confidence knotch
and every self-confidence knotch takes
you to a new new level
what guy I'm thrilled to be here I come
home here in this place and see this
magnificent crowd on a Friday afternoon
I can't thank you enough and visitors
remember this this economy is much more
than half full this country has got more
opportunity than it's ever had and every
one of you who see every graduate that's
here has got every chance in the world
to reach your dreams just go for it take
a swing and for God's sakes don't be
conservative have fun enjoy yourself